[Music]
ever since he first got his driver's
license at age 18 I was on fear and has
made a living out of dealing used cars
once a week he stocks up on merchandise
at the BCA car auction house where with
a bit of luck he can find real bargains
lots of carts need to be inspected
before the auction on Wednesday 253 this
time ferret checks the thickness of the
paint a private buyer wouldn't spot this
with the naked eye but if an expert
looks it over a bit you can see it it's
been touched up but not even an expert
can tell the paint's thickness with the
naked eye this must say this diesel is
four years old parrot is willing to pay
17,000 euros for it but he's competing
with 190 other dealers here there's not
as much money to be made in used cars as
there once was Spain Portugal and Greece
are no longer buying as many we're
having trouble selling because the
market prices are pretty low now the
prices have gone down a lot so if the
car doesn't sell what does that mean for
the sellers as a bindi photo you buy own
today if a vehicle gets left standing on
the lot we've got a real problem we'll
lower the prices to try to sell the cars
as fast as possible and not get stuck on
the non mover only professional dealers
are allowed to bid at the auctions
like outside more vehicles are unloading
for future options the option house sold
about 120 thousand cars in 2012 every
year the branch manager has more sellers
wanting to auction off their vehicles
thoughts embellishment is side Ford has
been selling through BCA since the very
first day we started up in Germany other
car makers that are on board are
mercedes-benz Renault Volvo Nissan and
Kia then we've got the banks and the big
dealership groups right down to the
smallest used car dealer everyone's
interested in our marketing concept
Philippe's concept into a center awesome
parent has his eye on a white station
wagon when babe after now that comes in
over the Internet
it finally goes for eighteen thousand
nine hundred euros out of fear entrain
j-- sometimes you get lucky sometimes
you don't you have to move on we'll try
for another one instead someone else
probably thought that price was
attractive parent often checks the
prices for comparable vehicles offered
on the internet to the auction house to
the importance of the Internet is
growing that's now we're getting 60 to
65% of our bidders through the internet
maybe even more with the rest physically
present in the hall but it's the dealers
in the hall who can make a big
difference because they helped to decide
the final price a vehicle evaluator
helps prepare the next auction
photographing every visible floor in
indirect light so that the online
bidders know exactly what they're
getting Shepard's avoider now I've
localized the dent I mark it with an
arrow and I'll market in the PDA as well
and pretty much the same spot where the
damage really is then I laid Ghent file
over it so the buyers who call up with
photo on the Internet can see the
distortion of the lines reveals the dent
so once he's telling revenues against
expenses has ferret turned a profit for
the day altogether we spent about 70
thousand euros and bought five cars
he'll drive this one right off the lot
for seventeen thousand eight hundred
euros including the surcharge this one
to me it was a bargain price for that
cars I would have paid more for it but
we got it for less now we'll have to see
that we sell it for a good price for
Colvin he'll be offering the car for
nineteen thousand euros
you